this is like a spy movie from people who
find spy movies right now just a little
bit borden like a kunai later you know
what the guys can i crack jokes when
they kill people and they had exploding
pens and the correspondent submarines
neveress them do you guys mess that in
spy movies we mess that too you know
it's like bonds but bond Calzaghe a know
you guys in the shoulder boats
afterwards as Tatem so this is a movie
from the week kick-ass was a love letter
so superheroes and everything we loved
about superheroes growing up this is a
love letter to the spy movies we mess
and I want you to meet all the people
who made this film
starting with my keuken spider thieve
watch men Gibbons are living legends
jingo pan the best screenwriter in the
business
Sophie Cookson Sir Colin Firth
sofia boutella and the man we all love
samuel l.jackson
I play this young man's mentor but in
reality I think the roles were quite
reversed I took so much information
inspiration from this boy and he taught
me an immense amount about how to
conduct myself in a film like this he's
absolutely delightful human being an
inspirational actor and he will not need
an introduction after this comes out
this is Taron Egerton my questions for
mr. Jackson you've been in a ton of
different movies spanning a number of
different genres I was wondering what
drew you to this movie and how you tend
to pick your roles um yeah I've been
watching James Bond movie since From
Russia With Love and I've always wanted
to be in one of course like everybody
else I wanted to be Bond I wanted to
have the gadgets and have the girls do
all that [ __ ] but hey an opportunity
presented itself to be in a film that's
very much like that and they asked me to
be what you would call the
quintessential body and villain I jumped
at it
I wanted to see myself in a movie like
this and that's how I chose it next
question please
hi you guys mentioned a a bond but when
I watched that clip I see a new version
of Steve from the Avengers did anybody
consider mentioning that while you were
on the set yeah
mix yeah bomb yes it's obvious you know
you have the pinstripes in the umbrella
the elegance the gentleman I don't think
this is has a debt only to bond by any
means I'd that certainly wasn't in in
our thinking it's only all the various
you know manifestations of the spy have
I think been referenced here and Steve
is very much one of them so is Harry
Palmer
you know it goes so is George Smiley in
a way so I think I think the debt to
John Steed definitely is to be
acknowledged I mean I would say that
it's almost an iconic figure the British
gentleman spy and I think we probably
all grew up a lot of different
influences in that vein
thanks Persian place Mike hi Mike
questions about I am making a british
film today and the challenges that faces
in regards of London and making a
production in Hollywood they said well I
don't I guess that's probably Jana the
best but for the network that Matthew
Vaughn is a miracle worker
he seems to have a completely different
set of rules than anyone else in the
British film industry and uh you know I
don't know how he does it it's alchemy
sometimes but yes it's it's hugely
challenging making films I think
probably in any territory but um
Matthew Vaughn is someone with
incredible determination and was you
know he's incredibly resourceful and he
when he gets it into his head to get a
movie made it just gets made
you